[Music]
britain passed a miserable milestone of
a hundred thousand
covert deaths this week it's a grim
statistic
a terrible toll which puts even more
pressure
on the vaccine rollout not just to lead
us out of lockdown
but to slash fatalities so far it's so
good
but there is some way to go yet i'm
joined by kate andrews
the editor of the spectators daily
covert 19
up dale update email you should get that
it's the only roundup you need
for the latest coronavirus news in
britain and abroad
kate update us and go through the latest
numbers please
as you can see here cases peaked around
the start of the year and are now
showing a clear trajectory of decline
with cases hovering around where they
were say december
20th roughly last year when tier 4 had
been brought in for millions of people
but
other areas of the uk remain slightly
more liberalized
as we know with this virus there is a
lag between infection and
hospitalization and you would expect if
cases were dropping at the start of the
month
that we would now start to see a decline
in hospitalization
this is by no means reflecting the
decline that you saw in cases in that
previous slide
but we have had some positive news from
the health service journal this morning
showing that case that coveted positive
patients in english hospitals
fell by nearly 1 500 yesterday
and they're describing that as the
biggest daily decline
recorded since the start of the pandemic
it reflects another big decline just
over a thousand
on the 17th of april which was the start
of a very
steep descent and but the fact
is andrew as you say we've hopefully
turned the tide on this wave of the
virus but that's not what's in
the main news this week uh the stark
number of the week is a hundred thousand
and that represents the uk's
accumulative
death toll coveted death toll since last
spring
the prime minister addressed the nation
this week saying he was deeply sorry
that he accepts responsibility
in his handling of this crisis something
that will no doubt be looked at in an
inquiry
down the line but i think there's little
doubt that the government wants
certain parts of the crisis focused on
more
than others and that is what is embodied
in the vaccine race and i can give you
an update on that
um now i don't want to get too
optimistic because we are a year into
this crisis the uk is in its third
lockdown so
let's not pretend things can't go wrong
but so far it is looking like quite a
remarkable success story
the uk's decision last year not to join
the european union and procuring
vaccines and going in alone instead
looks to be one of the best decisions
it's made during the crisis as well as
the idea to invest
across the board in multiple vaccines
despite at the time people thinking
there was a relatively low probability
that any of them would work and they
secured
over 350 million doses and that's
more than four jabs per adult
so that has been a remarkable success
for the uk
and what you're looking at here in this
graph has prompted some pretty
wild behavior from the european union
this week which understandably is
growing increasingly
desperate to get their hands on the
vaccine and but
less understandably has started to
undermine diplomacy
and order um this includes warning that
it might restrict exports of vaccines
made
in the block a suggestion of the erosion
of contract law
rejecting the notion of first come first
served now the uk is trying to stay out
of it
they're saying that this is this is a
dispute between the eu
and big pharma and the providers but it
is likely to be drawn in further
especially if pressure starts to mount
for the uk once it's most vulnerable
members of the population are vaccinated
to donate these vaccines um to the rest
of europe
um but there are other political
problems for the uk other fights to be
had um and this is a a graph showing
uh the the rate of vaccinations within
the four nations
and highlights a problem that boris
johnson has
not that england isn't doing well um but
he's up in scotland today
making the case for the union um an
issue that is becoming
um an increasing pressure point for the
prime minister
and it's charts like this that the prime
minister will use to make his case
that the union is stronger together that
westminster really had a handle not just
on procuring these vaccines
but also knowing how to administer them
and but these are crucial weeks for the
prime minister he needs to meet his
target of mid-february by having the
most for
vulnerable groups inoculated and again
reasons to be hopeful the current
projections and forecasts would suggest
that the uk might hit this target a day
or two
early which you can see in this graph
which you can see in this graph but
this is this is not just about turning
the tide on the virus it's very much
from a political perspective
perspective about turning the tide on
how we view this government it's
handling of cover 19 and how efficient
it really is um
on that note i'll throw back over to you
andrew hey thank you for that
let me bring in uh james forsyth our
political editor and katie bowles our
deputy
political editor to reflect on this
week's uh politics james the
the this milestone of a hundred thousand
deaths from covert which places amongst
per capita amongst the worst in terms of
performance the the human toll
is obvious and huge is the prime
minister
paying a political toll for us as well
not in the way i think that many people
in westminster had expected i still
think the public
don't view the virus they view the virus
as a kind of natural disaster in the way
that they would view
flooding or a hurricane rather than as a
kind of straightforward political issue
and so while i think the government does
obviously you know you look at how big
the government's leads were early in
this crisis when the rally round the
flag effect was in
was in full force and where they are now
yeah
obviously the mistakes made have taken a
toll on the government's poll ratings
but we're still in a situation where
labour are marginally ahead
uh you go up today gave them a slightly
bigger lead than usual four points
but yeah we're still kind of we're still
in a world where the two bodies are are
are if you kind of average out the poles
neck and neck and i think you
i mean the big question as as k andrew
said in terms of the public's view on
this is
what happens with the vaccine roll out
because i think that if at the end of
this crisis the uk is
coming out of it before other countries
then i think the public will
take a more benign view of the
government's handling of the whole
crisis
but if the vaccine ends up being hit by
some of the same problems that ppe
procurement was or track and trace was
then i think the public's view will
become much more negative
and so i i essentially the the
the the the what will determine how the
public look back on the government's
handling of this crisis
is this vaccine rollout katie is that is
that the politics of it that the
the mistakes of the government made in
2020 uh
were many some of them very big and
they're pretty well cataloged now we
know
what they are from test and trace to
protective equipment and
other things being slow to lock down
when it should have done
but is the thought in government that in
the end that won't matter so much if
if they get the vaccine roll out right
in other words
what will stay in people's memories is
is as is a successful
exit from the pandemic rather than the
unsuccessful periods of the pandemic
last year
yes i i do think now the focus in
government is actually you can turn
things around by having that positive
vaccine story
you see it this week um lots of coverage
of the fact we have passed a hundred
thousand deaths but also lots of
coverage of this
positive vaccine development and there's
that juxtaposition going i think there's
still difficult points for the
government
i think if you look at the figures and
how we've reached a hundred thousand
the number of deaths from november is
really startling
uh you know this wasn't all in the first
wave in fact
i think this idea the government had
which you make mistakes in the beginning
i think you could argue they made
mistakes up until very recently
um but but ultimately i think the sense
in number 10
is if they can keep up uh the pace
currently on vaccinations
if they can be the leading country
across europe
then that's what people are going to
remember and that is what you're going
to get to this summer and
i think it's no coincidence that there
is lots of talk about postponing the
local elections in may
all of a sudden the government are quite
keen to have them that's because they
think they're getting a vaccine boost
james when the government announced that
it was not going to be part of the eu
procurement
uh approach uh which it could have been
as i understand
even though we were no longer in the eu
uh the sort of the the london chattering
classes uh
went mad saying how disgraceful
this is is this is nationalism run riot
and
brexiteer and nutters and so on they're
not saying that now
aren't they no and i think what it is i
think it showcases the the
the advantages of being a nimble country
being able to move
quickly not having to move at the
slowest pace uh
the uk basically went for emergency
authorization rather than the full
authorization that the european
medicines agency is going through with
these vaccines
and the uk is essentially trying to
trying to get the vaccine rolled out as
fast as it is produced
and i think that that is that has given
the uk
an advantage i think the other big
advantage the uk has
is that it has a the population in
europe that is by far the most willing
to take the vaccine
so that means that you don't have to go
slowly to try and build public
confidence in the way that it's
happening in some other countries i
don't think it's any coincidence
but denmark is one of the eu countries
that has made the most progress
and that has the second most
pro-vaccination population in europe
after the uk i think that that public
willingness to take the vaccine
is a crucial part of the success of the
uk vaccine rollout
whereas in france which is a rather
surprisingly quite frighteningly large
anti-vax
movement so far less than two percent of
the population have had
the vaccine we we've seen brussels
sort of beat the drum this week james
almost implying that they may be looking
at stopping
pfizer exports from there to the united
kingdom
kind of implying that britain should be
sending over a chunk of its
astrazeneca supplies to
uh the eu the european press
very unimpressed with brussels
records so far how do you think this is
going to work out
well i i i think the uk government is
very keen to stay out of this row
um because i think it i think it fears
that the uh that there are
european politicians looking for any
excuse to essentially say well we're
halting
these advisor exports to the uk so the
uk is very keen to out of it but one
thing i would say is
look at the amount of noise the eu is
making in this route
if you are confident that you have a
legal remedy to your problem
you tend not to make a public song and
dance about it you just instruct your
lawyers
so i think i think the fact that the the
eu is making this much
of a you know talking about the
astrazeneca's societal and moral
obligations
suggests that it isn't confident of a
legal remedy i mean the uk's view is
but when they uh that oxford university
came to uk government said look we want
you to be happy
with the vaccine deal we are negotiating
considering it's important
and the uk government said look we want
a
legally watertight guarantee that the uk
will have first
access to the doses produced in this
country
that actually led to oxford not
partnering with merck the
the pharmaceutical company that they
were expected to and instead with a bit
of government matchmaking pastor and
partnering with astrazeneca
but that is because the uk got more in
its contract than just a best effort
scores best endeavors clause
which is what the ceo of astrazeneca
says the eu has
in its contract with astrazeneca so i
think the the uk i think is on stronger
legal ground here
uh in terms of having first refusal on
the supply coming out of the uk
i think that it would be a it would be a
massive step for all the reasons that
kate said out in our presentation
if the the eu were to go down the route
that the german government is advocating
and impose full and export controls on
vaccines from the block if you had a
situation where
pfizer were unable to fulfill
a contract that has been signed and paid
for with the uk government because of eu
action
that that would be quite a massive
escalation
and casey we've seen some some strange
stories that got going around this
um not not just the uh the health
commissioner from greece saying
you know we don't we don't believe in
first come first serve but
this story in handles blatt which uh the
german financial paper which is a paper
i know a little bit about this paper it
has a
incredible reverence for facts you know
it facts checks
everything and as a kind of almost
germanic
thoroughness about how it reports things
and yet it came out with a report
that said the astrazeneca
uh vaccine was only effective for eight
percent
of over 65s which the german government
and astrazeneca
both said it's nonsense and yet it
doubled down on the story uh
what does the british government make of
all this i think
ministers are perplexed i think there's
also a sense of annoyance i think some
are actually seething at what they see
as disinformation in terms of
uh what's coming out because also i
think there is a sense you touch on the
fact that publication is known for
actually wanting to publish facts i
think there is a there is a sense that
this isn't coming from nowhere
i think they worry that someone is
actually negatively briefing a
within government against uh the oxford
vaccine perhaps for reasons if you look
at the whole events of the week
and as you say the publication doubled
down and i think it
as this thing is there is a huge row
going on at the moment about
you know vaccine wars about the oxford
vaccine about the lack of supply
the eu haven't yet approved the oxford
vaccine they can't actually use it yet
i think they're you know several million
doses ready to go when when they do
approve it
but i think we're looking ahead now to
friday
when we're expecting it could be
approved and while
uh i think the eight percent efficacy uh
line has been
widely rebuffed you've had you know
german government come out against
it i think that where these publications
are still saying
there could be something is is it going
to be approved for
the elderly is there going to be an age
limit in the eu approval and i think
the only way we're going to find out the
truth in terms of the smoke and mirrors
at the moment
is a journalist having an incredibly bad
week or is there something more to it is
when they
announce their decision on approval well
uh
vaccine wars is the cover story of the
spectator this week it's got a great
cover and it's a two-page spread
on what's going on by matthew lynn it's
well worth a read
[Music]
you